hello welcome to another us
election special for spectator tv now
you can get 10
off a subscription to our monthly
american edition if you go to
spectator.us forward slash subscribe
then enter the promo code tv you'll get
the subscription and you'll also get a
free whiskey tumbler
you might need it on the night of
november the 3rd that's an offer only
for you
spectator tv viewers now today
i'm joined by mallory newell the poster
for ipsy's mooring
by john rick mcarthur the president of
harper's magazine
as well as by the spectator's very own
amber aphey our washington editor
and our u.s editor freddie gray and we
start with the big question
on everybody's mind as donald trump
already lost
the first presidential debate was hardly
a success for him then he caught covet
propelling his handling of the pandemic
to the front of the campaign which is
not where
republicans want it then it was revealed
that the west wing had become an
epicenter of the pandemic
which hardly encouraged confidence in
the administration
that followed a series of increasingly
bizarre tweets and statements
culminating in a presidential
infomercial
because that's what it looked like
promising to supply
every american free with a drug still
under trial
that might or might not have helped him
recover
the president was already on the wrong
side of the polls and the past week
they've turned against him
even more so is the trump presidency
all over bar the tweeting let's go first
to
mallory knew she's as i said with ipsos
mori the
the poster what are the polls now
telling us mallory you've got
some slides i think looking at national
polling about the presidential race
our episodes polling shows that really
over time
up until recently the presidential race
had been
quite steady joe biden had maintained a
anywhere from seven to ten point lead in
the market
however what we're seeing now is that
this has probably been
joe biden's best week according to the
polls with him
gaining slightly on president trump and
over
that precious 50 threshold both in our
polling and
in other national polls that we've seen
released this week
so if he's uh the average i saw is
he's almost 10 points ahead of the
president now
i mean the polls would have to be
catastrophically out
for mr trump to win would they not
that's right and i think what we're
seeing here is that if the status quo
holds if these polls continue to show
what they're showing now
then certainly november 3rd or
thereafter given that
we don't actually know when the final
results will come in because of
mail-in ballots but given what we're
seeing now if the status quo holds
then it's likely that joe biden is
elected the next president of the united
states
and i look at the uh the average
of the polls in the battleground states
take florida pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin north carolina
arizona mr biden's
lead there has gone up a little bit
there too it's an average lead in these
states
of about 4.5 now that is closer to the
margin of error
but it's still quite significant in
pennsylvania i see
he's a he's ahead by seven points and
that's
uh you know mr trump won pennsylvania by
a narrow margin in 2016.
that's quite significant seven points in
pennsylvania
yes if you turn an eye to the three
upper midwest states that president
trump won
so very narrowly in 2016 so that's
pennsylvania
wisconsin and my home state of michigan
we're seeing now that the polling
is certainly looking better for joe
biden in those three states
outside of the margin of error as you
pointed out there's currently an
approximately seven point lead in
pennsylvania for
the former vice president now again we
have to keep in mind that
there isn't necessarily one thing that's
pointing to the lead in these polls this
week it's been a busy week for the
president and a busy week in the news
cycle
so we can't exactly say what is
contributing to this
incremental boost for joe biden in the
polls but one thing that we do know is
that it is pretty consistent
across the entire country as well as
some key battleground states
well let's just go through some of the
big things that have happened to see if
the polling can tell us anything in the
past
week or so a little bit more than a week
we know from the polling that
most americans thought
that he hadn't done well in the first
presidential debate is that right
that's correct the first presidential
debate i think americans were just
completely taken aback at what happened
but generally speaking our polling and
others show
that the president did not have a good
performance
do we know is there polling yet to show
what the impact of the announcement
that he had covered and the subsequent
behavior
result of that from the drive by out of
the hospital
to the information infomercial on the
lawn of the white house promising all
this marvelous drug do we know what
impact that's having
on public opinion
well one thing that we need to keep in
mind is that
public opinion and just generally the
political landscape right now is so
incredibly polarized
that many americans views about the
president are already baked in
you know i think we can look at the
president's approval rating
this week and it has remained unchanged
and frankly the president's approval
rating
has remained completely steady ever
since the pandemic began and even before
so he basically what that shows is that
views about the president are already
baked in and his announcement
of having covet 19 and all of the
subsequent follow-up from that
you know it may be contributing to this
slight boost for biden that we're seeing
in the polls but it's really not doing
much to move public opinion
around president's approval rating or
how they feel about the president's
handling of cobit 19
which was negative even before he
contracted the virus
and maybe one reason why in a number of
states florida a good example
he's not doing so well among older
people in 2016
he kind of mocked up the older white
vote
in places like florida pennsylvania and
so on
but i was seeing some studies that show
he's not doing as well among that
demographic now because
that's the most vulnerable group when it
comes to covid and they don't think he's
done that well in covet
that's right generally the american
public
disapproves of the job that the
president has done when it comes to
handling the coven 19 pandemic and
the president's approval on the virus
tracks very closely to his overall
approval rating
so what that means is for the american
public they're really
not able to separate out their views on
trump
and their views on trump's handling of
the virus
now as you mentioned senior citizens
those older than 65
have traditionally voted for republican
candidates in the past
in larger numbers president trump
included and we're starting to see a
little bit of a shift
however it's important to note that that
shift didn't just
come up out overnight in the past week
or so we've started to see incremental
movement among older americans
toward joe biden for some time
but what's the mood okay
but what's the mood in the trump
campaign are they beginning to
to wonder whether it's all over
or at least whether they're faced with
mission impossible
what i hear from my friends who work on
the campaign is that
they will never admit that there is a
chance that trump could lose and i think
that's something they probably warn
staffers
about talking about even privately they
want people to keep this optimistic
outlook on the election however i will
say i know multiple people who work in
the administration
and they have become worried about their
job prospects over the next few months
and have expressed
concern to me privately that they could
be
unemployed come the new year and will
soon have to start looking for a new job
and figuring out their health insurance
situation
so i would say that the mood is
definitely more somber within the white
house than it is on the campaign
but if only because the campaign is
trying to both publicly and privately
put on
this very optimistic face so that the
base does not get discouraged
which is sensible from their uh point of
view
rick mccaffer how do you read the the
polls at the at the moment
is is it all over or do we have to be a
bit more cautious
than that well i i'm always a little bit
more cautious because i don't
uh admire the polling that was done
in 2016 um for obvious reasons
but what is interesting to me and i'd
like uh
uh hope mallory could comment on this is
that
there are new battleground states that
weren't battleground states before like
texas
if you look at texas uh biden is almost
even in some polls with uh with trump
and texas is the reddest of the red
states we thought
now they have a week the democrats have
a fairly weak senatorial candidate who
will probably lose
to corbyn the incumbent but biden is
is very close to winning texas and if he
wins texas
it is over it is over it's over i mean
what's the latest from texas
i think polls in texas right now are are
too close to call right
at this point in time and we need to
remember that that's what polling is as
a snapshot in time of the current moment
uh it's it's hard to say that biden has
a lead in texas or trump has a lead
it's within the margin of error but i
think what we're seeing in texas
actually speaks to a broader pattern of
what's happening
in america and that's a changing
demographic landscape
in this country this country is becoming
younger more racially diverse and i
think that's going to be reflected in
this
new battleground map democrats are
working to
make plays for states that perhaps they
haven't in the past such as texas and
georgia
there's a strong senate race in arizona
that shows a democrat leading the
republican
incumbent so again i think the democrats
play here
is to work to expand the electoral map
and putting effectively the trump
campaign on defense this time around
i mean the demographic changes have been
a long time coming and
you know george is the state that's
always going to go democrat
and never quite does it we'll see if it
happens this time everybody's waiting to
see if it
where the other virginia is i mean you
see the demographic change
most of all in virginia uh which has now
become a
basically a blue blue state partly
because of the northern
suburbs of virginia basically washington
dc and texas
will be interesting for sense that maybe
texas may take another election
before it quite goes that way but mr
biden winning
uh texas is not quite as ludicrous as
the idea that mr trump could win
california freddie
yet he did say that he could win
california i mean
has he lost the plot entirely now it's
always hard to know with trump because
of course it seems insane but
he sort of gets away with it because
while he's playing all these sort of
crazy games and saying that he could win
california and win in new york he does
change
dynamics elsewhere and i think i mean
that
the only thing it does look very bleak
for the republicans at the moment but i
think the only thing really
uh that they can cling on to it's this
fact that on the economy
he is more trusted there's going to be
this fight over a stimulus bill looks
like he might be able to pull
a rabbit out of a hat on that if he can
get a sense that
he's got the american he's recovered
from covid in record time
and he's getting the american economy
back on track he may be able to do
something and you really shouldn't
underestimate
trump's ability to pull victory uh from
the jaws of chaotic defeat
i mean let's remember just before the
second debate in 2016
it was the moment of the bully bishop
bully bush tape which was of course
trump making these misogynistic remarks
and he had a collapse in the polling
then
and he somehow managed to win so never
underestimate his ability to bounce back
but
it is looking pretty dire at the moment
remember what's the game plan so
there's the republican campaign the
the past week is what it is that's where
we are now
uh things have not been going well
but it's a little way to go to november
the third and his freddie says
um who knows what's the game plan what
what are the repub what's the republican
campaign the trump campaign going to do
to turn it around
to get back to be a contender
right of course they lost an entire week
due to trump's cova diagnosis which was
a huge blow because at this point they
would have wanted the president
going to battleground states and doing
these rallies in places like minnesota
and wisconsin and michigan
and they were unable to do that so what
they did instead is they launched this
new uh program i guess you could call it
called
operation maga and they're getting vice
president mike pence more involved
and they're putting the trump kids on
bus tours and sending them around the
country
to basically fill in for the president
and the places where
you know he can't travel right now
because of this coba diagnosis it's
unclear if that's what
is really needed though because trump
can always rely on his base
what is changing the polls now though
are these undecided voters
or the voters who went from obama to
trump back in 2016.
so the idea that donald trump jr going
to a rally in florida is going to
make those people more likely to support
the president seems
like not exactly a winning strategy rick
do you think there's anything
the trump campaign can do to
to stem i mean it's like a sort of
negative moment i remember
george bush the first hw but she used to
talk about the big mo
that he'd come out of primaries with the
big mo
and momentum works in both directions at
the moment the moment the momentum seems
to be
in a downward spiral for the president
what what can he do can you do anything
to turn it around well i thought he had
a chance in the debate
as bad as he was uh
biden is a very weak candidate and a
very weak debater uh
he got off easy in that debate because
trump was so horrible
he made biden look a little bit more uh
well behaved let's say but certainly not
not more articulate in fact he was less
articulate than trump
uh but there was a crucial moment
where biden asked criticized trump
about his trade policy and as we all
should know
trump won by uh by hair's breadth
because of nafta and uh
pntr permanent normal trade trading
relations with china which
did cause a huge outflow of industrial
jobs to mexico and china
and those people who switched from obama
to
trump many of them are unemployed or
formerly
employed factory workers who switched
parties
they were so angry about and nafta is a
still a dirty word
and trump did had a chance there to
clobber biden
uh with his unfailing support for
everything that the establishment
democrats have pushed for for years
on so-called free trade and he didn't
say a word
he let it pass to which which brings me
to your question do they have a game
plan
they don't have a game plan because
their only game plan was that trump
would sort of wing it
uh things would get better the virus
might disappear
or at least uh lessen uh and
um biden would shoot himself in the foot
which he's very capable of doing
but yeah and so far so far it's not
happening
so my if i were his advisor i would tell
him to to quiet down
and hope that biden makes a mistake and
then when he comes out
come up with some talking points but
they can't get trump
to follow talking points that's not
trump uh
it's it's important to make the
distinction between as somebody who's a
narcissist
and a solipsist it was explained to me
by a psychologist
robert lifted a psalm says for a
solstice the only point of reference
for trump is himself a narcissist at
least
seeks the love of others and the
attention of others
he doesn't list he doesn't listen to
anyone else no one else only wants to
talk about
himself he doesn't want to talk about
the economy he doesn't want to talk
about
the trade wars with uh china he wants to
talk about it on himself
right and regeneron the the magic
which is now which she now endorses in
that infomercial
um basically what it was
you see you can see
a way forward look it's i think it's an
uphill climb
but it ain't all over uh
there is a way forward that could narrow
the gap and still keep
the president in contention but freddie
the problem is
as i was told by someone who's very
close to him a couple of days ago
he's pumped up on steroids he's out of
control
he doesn't listen to anybody now and
it's basically just him
and if that's true what rick is saying
is
that there isn't a campaign it's just
him so i don't
know how you turn that round it's just
him doing infomercials
as you so accurately called i thought
the only thing lacking was that
the bit at the end where they say you
know side effects may include
that's because they're not quite sure of
the side effects of this drug yet
but i would say there is one there is
one thing they may not necessarily have
a particularly good game plan
uh team trump but they do i think have a
better ground game or at least they seem
to
in the battleground states um what's
interesting about biden harris is that
uh they have a very sophisticated
digital operation
uh they seem to be handling the media as
well as they can because it's slightly
easier for them
but as i understand their ground game in
ohio is very very poor
in pennsylvania it should be strong in
the are ahead but it doesn't seem to be
operating
very well and if this is not a
persuasion election but a turnout
election
that could help trump that of course is
mitigated by this huge
male male in ballot issue which of
course
reduces the importance of turnout
well you carried a piece we'll finish up
on this segment but you carried a piece
in the
spectator usa from one of our
journalists
showing the way that and it talked about
the grand campaign
so if you're watching and you're a trump
supporter
and you don't want to give up hope you
should read that piece in spectator usa
because it did show
that there was a way forward with the
grand campaign
and other factors uh going right and
more registrations
and um if that was to be the case all
would not be lost
who was the author of that freddie that
uh that was matt meyer
i think he was cool and he wrote uh he's
he's based in ohio and he wrote a piece
about it and it was interesting that
there was an enormous amount of traffic
uh to that piece and it was coming as we
can geo located it was coming from swing
state so i think there is this
subterranean sense in a lot of these
battleground states that
there's something that isn't being
picked up here okay
now some 58 million americans finally
saw this week what they had not
experienced the week before
a proper debate this time between vice
president mike pence and joe biden's
running mate senator
kamala harris it was civil the two
candidates discussed
matters of state even policy it was also
even a little bit boring in parts like
many debates are
amber several polls suggested that
kamala harris have got the better of
mike pence not by
a landslide but that she had quote won
but you wrote on the spectator uh usa
website
that mr pence took her to the cleaners
why did you think that mike pence ended
up being donald trump's best advocate
and he really made
those points that trump has been unable
to about biden's handling of the economy
about his
horrible trade deals in terms of nafta
and normalizing relations with china as
rick just said
but how you can really tell that mike
pence won this debate was the media
reaction to kamala's performance
every media story and cable news pundit
talked about
not what she said during the debate not
how she um
made the case for the biden ticket but
about her facial expressions and how she
responded to mike pence supposedly
mansplaining her and being sexist toward
her
and if the media had to make the story
about this sexist
vice president taking down this strong
independent woman
and not about the substance of what she
actually said or how she was selling
herself then you know
that she was not a successful debater
mallory 58 million people that's a lot
of people watching a vice presidential
debate it's not a record
um but it's high
but do they have any influence on the
campaign the advice of the vp debates
well here's what we know about debates
not just the vp debates but
frankly debates are very unlikely to
move the needle a candidate might see a
short bump immediately
following but as we know this time
around there are so
few undecided voters and people are so
already entrenched into their own policy
positions
that a debate really isn't likely to be
a huge game changer
now ipsos did some polling before and
after the vp debate in
in coordination with 538 and what we saw
is that first of all a majority of
americans thought that
the debate overall was good something
that
people did not say from the first
presidential debate
they also felt that both harris and
pence had good performances but the area
where there was a little bit of
differentiation
is on policy and most americans felt
that kamala harris put forth good
policies
while far fewer said that about mike
pence
so overall they were pleased with the
debate pleased with the candidates
performances but where there is a little
bit of differentiation
was on substance and what they had to
say
right given the age of the two people
heading up the tickets
the vice president's never been more
important
because either of them could end up
being president before the four years is
out
how do you rate uh komala harris
well i think she's terrible i i i think
she's a
terrible mediocrity i if if i'd been
advising
uh biden i would have told him to uh
pick somebody like sharon brown from
ohio and that way he would have locked
up the midwestern states
but i i think she's just terrible and
she actually made pence look good
because pence looked more
to me more uh articulate and composed
now
i i come from the left i'm not a i'm not
a pro
uh trump or pence person but a left-wing
friend of mine a french intellectual
said to me just this morning uh that
watching the debate made him think
let's hope for god's sake that uh uh
biden survives that biden looks to him
much better
as a person and as a politician
uh as a person of substance than kamala
harris
because i i think what what amber's
getting at is
her talking points were all that there
was
she looked at the camera like a like uh
she was a pitch she was being a pitch
person and she wasn't being a debater
she wasn't thinking on her feet
and that has to make anybody who's
serious about the future of the country
queasy
i wouldn't want pence to be president
but he certainly i thought he came off
as
more composed more uh more
in some respects more real than her
there seemed there was a sort of lack of
empathy coming from
kamala harris that she did seem to be a
sort of talking points
candidate almost a a policy wonk and
yeah when it came to one of the biggest
policies or one of the biggest talking
points on
whether or not if if mr biden gets the
white house and the senate
that would they stack the supreme court
neither he nor she
are prepared to answer that question
rick
why not and doesn't that harm them i
i thought it did uh uh but again uh
amber i'm sorry um uh mallory's probably
right that these
by special vice presidential debates
don't make any difference these are too
obscure
things like the supreme court don't
really move most americans
covet 19 is what moves americans not
not who's who's going to be the the
deciding vote on roe versus wade i
really don't think that
moves people but but uh i do think that
she came off as
an empty a very empty person just
there's just not much to her
pretty yeah
i was quite surprised by uh mr pence's
performance
because i've always thought of him as
being a rather underwhelming
pretty wooden public speaker and debate
at freddy and um
he actually see he he seemed to be
across the issues
yes i mean it's not it wasn't lincoln
douglas
but he seemed to be across the issues
and more articulate than
i had thought he was and at the end
at the end he taught you told that it's
become a cliche
already but he told the story about how
ruth bader ginsburg and antonin
scalia used to socialize uh even though
they were
at ideological odds on the supreme court
and i thought that was very effective
and of course
if you really do believe in the american
ideal
that's a good thing you want
you want the left and the right on the
supreme court to get along
to talk to one another ready i
i thought i thought he was very
impressive actually i thought much more
impressive i've seen him speak a few
times
much more impressive than i've seen him
before uh he was let down by this
the the bloody eye which is what
everybody was talking about on social
media
and then of course this large fly
landing
right here just staying there for a good
two
three minutes do you think donald trump
sent that fly
because my pence was showing him up i
think there may have been some something
in that i was worried the fly was going
to
come out of the eye at one point did he
know the fly was there i mean
he can't he can't have done otherwise he
would have surely he's not
a nice thing ahead of here so maybe he
didn't feel anything uh
amber were there maybe some thoughts on
them among the republicans that hey
maybe if mike pence was ahead of the
chick we
might be doing a bit better you know a
lot of people said that to me after the
debate if only mike pence were the one
going around
on the campaign trail and making the
case for trumpism or trump populism
then he would have blown out joe biden
and it really did make a lot of people
wonder why he has been doing such little
campaigning over the past couple of
months
and especially among suburban women
because mike pence would presumably be a
much more attractive option to them in
more ways than one maybe
than uh president donald trump who of
course they don't like his personality
they don't like
his petty jobs or the way he uses his
twitter account
and they i would say that suburban women
were definitely turned off a little bit
by
kamala harris's behavior during the
debate where she made everything about
gender
and had these very snarky eye rolls and
um the way she was really comporting
herself that's not something that really
appeals
to women who are independent-minded
that's more of a liberal wine mom type
of yes queen
ideology so mike pence really should be
on the campaign trail more
and you know trying to get those voters
that maybe
historically have been turning up their
nose at
trump well that's a violence
presidential debate there's only one in
this campaign of 2020
but there's next week's debate or is
there will there be one
now following the president's covert
diagnosis the commission
on presidential debates which is
independent of republicans and democrats
has said that the next tv debate
scheduled for
thursday october the 15th next week in
other words
should be held virtually but donald
trump rejected this virtual format and
his campaign have asked for the event
to be moved to the 22nd a week back so
that it can be done in the more
traditional
in-person tower and hall format the
biden campaign
has said that that's not acceptable to
them
so amber straight to you with your ear
to the ground and the big question
is there going to be a second debate at
this point it certainly doesn't seem
like it um
the biden campaign like you just said is
not willing to delay the debate to
october 22nd
and they don't want to do it in person
at all at this point which i think makes
sense for them it would obviously be
easier for joe biden to do a virtual
debate given his various issues
but trump would never agree to a virtual
debate and in fact i think the idea of a
virtual debate is pretty silly to begin
with if you thought the interruptions
were bad the first time around
now imagine trying to do that over a
zoom call it would certainly be a
disaster
and you asked me earlier why i thought
mike pence won the vice presidential
debate
and part partly because the uh
presidential
uh debate commission the following
morning at 7 a.m after that debate
announced unilaterally that they were
going to have a virtual debate for the
second presidential debate
that was not something that was
negotiated between the two campaigns
that was something that was decided just
by them
usually what happens is the two
campaigns and the debate commission will
actually sit down in a room together
and have verbal negotiations over what
the rules are going to be who the
moderator is going to be and they
reached a conclusion
and that's not what happened here so i
if i were on the trump campaign i too
would be similarly
um disappointed and unwilling to
abide by this change given the fact that
they did not allow either campaign to
weigh in
can mr trump afford not to have another
debate i mean he
he was generally perceived as mallory
was telling us the polls bear this
out too generally perceived not to have
done where his
bullying tactics didn't pay off mr biden
survived them he didn't fall in his face
he didn't disappear
into a word salad uh mr trump did not
come across well i think particularly
the suburban women didn't think he could
this is not the kind of man they want to
see
as president he's behind in the polls
he's
been slipping further uh sure he's the
one that needs
the debate he surely he cannot
do without another debate rick yes i i
think he does need another debate
that the question is whether it will
actually help him whether he's capable
of getting his game up
to the point where he can score some
points actually
he doesn't have much of an attention
span again he has
almost no attention span so in order to
get him to think
i'm going to go from point a to point b
in this debate
and make x y and z points is is a
is a stretch but assuming he could do it
it might help him a little bit at this
point but he's done himself
so much damage and and covet 19 is so
dominant as a as a subject in the in the
national debate
uh and you can't you can't uh uh subvert
this
you can't change the statistics uh
the cases are still rising in states
like michigan and wisconsin
and that's all over the news and there's
nothing he can do about that
all biden has to say as inarticulate as
as bad as he is on his feet is say well
look at look at the cove in 19 situation
is it getting any better
mr president and i think he wins that he
wins the day
i think that's exactly right if you know
regardless of whether there's another
debate or not
if the campaign continues to be shaped
by covet 19
you know that's an advantage for the
biden campaign
if the president can somehow reframe it
around the economy which as freddie
noted earlier
is a good issue for him then maybe that
changes the game a bit
but as we saw in the vice presidential
debate and certainly as we've seen in
the past few days
with the news of the president's
diagnosis
you know right now the focus is on
covid19 that's the number one issue that
americans care about
including those suburban women that
we've been talking about and
frankly that's what's taking up all of
the oxygen
in the proverbial room i didn't answer
your question andrew uh if i can
paraphrase
uh trump's infamous line you know you
could walk down fifth avenue and shoot
somebody
get away with it if if biden the
equivalent would be a biden said yeah i
want to stack the supreme court i want
to put 40
uh left wingers on and and and
with five right wingers or what he could
say he could say nobody would care
nobody would believe he just don't care
anymore i don't think that's a
an issue he's not going to say it he's
not doing it
because i get the point but rick i
thought his answer yesterday was even
more ludicrous when he was asked
uh if he would stack the court he'd say
oh i'm not going to tell you that
until after the election and then he
said
because if i told you you've heard a
story about it
i mean isn't that freddie he's between a
rock and a hard place
yes my guess is that as a mainstream
democrat
he does not want to stack the supreme
court
i mean he he knows enough about history
to know that it
rebounded badly on fdr and indeed fdr
in 1937 pulled out of doing it such was
and he controlled the house and the
senate
uh by bigger majorities as mr biden is
likely to do
if he does both at all but on the other
hand
he knows his base his left-wing base
wants to stack the supreme court they
will not accept a 6-3
conservative majority so he doesn't want
to do it but he doesn't want to say he
doesn't want to do it
is that right i think that is right but
the issue's not going to go away we're
going to have amy cody barrett's
hearings next week no i understand
that's going to get contentious it's not
going to disappear as an issue and of
course
trump is so desperate for something he
can use to to drive the left and then
and
the center left if you like a part uh
that that might be a an opening for him
amber just supposing there is another
debate
an in-person debate like the one uh the
first presidential
debate to be different in some ways but
broadly debates as we have known them
between the two presidential candidates
up what do you think trump's tactic
would be
would it be to repeat what he did last
time would it be
something different would it be to
channel his mike pence
what do you think well historically
trump does
tend to get better with each debate so
hopefully he would learn something from
the last performance
and stay a little bit more on message in
terms of what i think he should talk
about
as everyone on this uh in the show has
mentioned
the coronavirus is still a huge issue
for americans and the
trump campaign has to think of a way to
reframe that issue in a way that's
positive for them
whether that's refocusing on the economy
or
the way i think they should do it is
actually steal a line from the biden
campaign just as bad and stole the buy
america platform from trump
they should steal this idea of the
return to normalcy candidate joe biden
has of course fashioned himself as the
return to normalcy
after the whirlwind that has been the
trump era the trump
campaign and trump and mike pence should
talk about themselves as the return to
normalcy candidates
in terms of the coronavirus we still
have not gotten a clear answer from the
biden campaign
on whether or not they would shut down
the economy again and have another
coronavirus lockdown and really have not
talked about specifically
what they would have done differently
from the trump administration in the
early days of the coronavirus
so if pence and trump can fashion
themselves as the people that want to
still slowly reopen the economy allow
people's kids to go back to school
that could potentially be a way to spin
this issue as
being something that works in their
favor well enormously
normalcy works for candidates
particularly after times of great
disruption it worked for warren harding
in 1920 that's what he campaigned on and
it came after the first world war
it came after the spanish flu there's an
echo of today there were race riots in
america at the time there were
arguments about immigration and and so
on
and uh mr harding won by a landslide
campaigning on let's just
get back to normal and i can see mr
biden's doing that at the moment it
would be interesting if mr trump
was to steal these clothes of course not
long after mr harding ran into teapot
dome
and it didn't go so well after that but
it is interesting how well he did just
saying
because i think i get a sense uh rick
people even republicans they're they're
a bit exhausted by donald trump
yes they just i mean they wake up and
they know what's he done now
what are we doing oh can we not just be
a bit more
normal is that is that fair yes and i'm
glad you brought that up
i just add to what you said that harding
followed woodrow wilson and people were
exhausted
by wilson's vainglory he was
he was one of the most egotistical and
arrogant
uh uh he was something of a solid system
self
one of the most arrogant and
vainglorious presidents in american
history
people were sick of his big ideas about
re-escaping the world
just as uh people are sick of trump's uh
spasmodic ravings
and i so and his bluster let's say
uh so yes and i want to talk if we could
i don't know i want to change the
subject exactly but what's the response
of the republican
party if trump loses uh paranoid
left-wingers
who i know think that they're going to
there's going to be blood in the streets
uh
trump is going to incite riots uh
there's a lot of people walking around
with ar-15s who'd like to use them and
so on and so forth
a lot of that depends on how the
official republican party responds
uh to a trump defeat if that is if that
happens
and and i don't think any of them will
be sorry to see
trump go even uh his acolytes like tom
cotton
again i i could be corrected by amber
but i don't see even a tom cotton uh
type
the senator from arkansas uh who fancies
himself
something of a trump a trump successor
i don't see them uh stoking the rage of
the mob
say uh turning trump into a martyr i
think they may say well we're well rid
of them
we got what we wanted out of them we got
a big tax cut
we got the supreme court justices we
wanted etc etc
uh let's move on and get our party back
and get our party back have a quick
response
punish reward our friends and punish our
enemies
amber yeah i think that's exactly right
um the establishment
parts of the party obviously are going
to be happy to see trump go because
they're going to want to go back to the
pre-populist notion of this aggressively
free market
more libertarian-leaning republican
party that is in bed with big business
and even in the more populist wing of
the party where you have
tom cotton josh hawley marco rubio these
people are going to be thrilled to have
that power vacuum open up because they
see themselves
as the natural successors to trump and
speaking to that wing of the party so if
he's out of the picture
their message is going to be well it
didn't not work because
the ideology was bad it was because the
messenger was bad
and we are here to show that populism
can have more coherent voices more
presidential voices
and we're going to be um those people to
fill that gap oh
trump is also worth noting too if you
look at polling recently
so we at ipsos have been tracking the
the country direction and the mood in
america for a long time
and over the past few months one trend
that we've started to see
is that the mood among the republican
base
has started to sour a bit fewer
republicans
are saying that the country is headed in
the right direction
compared to pre-pandemic and even in the
first
few months of the pandemic you know
still
a majority are there about say that
things are headed in the right direction
so i don't want to overstate this too
much but we're talking a pretty
significant shift
from a vast majority say eight in ten
republicans to
close to half thinking that things are
headed in the right direction which to
me looking at that
is just another indicator that the mood
in this country
is becoming increasingly more negative
on both sides frankly
and that might make it more difficult
for mr trump to get his core
his base out if the bases are because he
needs that
massive turnout in his base and if the
an element of that base is
beginning to wonder if the country's
going in the right direction that would
undermine the his core is much smaller
than joe biden's cause so he needs a
differential
uh big turnout compared to the biden one
i want to move on to our final subject
today
uh because it's something that's really
never been talked about in
u.s presidential elections and that is
what we're calling mail-in madness
some 6.6 million americans have already
cast their ballots
in this year's election more than 10
times the number
at this time in 2016. now this of course
is in part due to the pandemic
but it does reflect a broader pattern in
american politics which has been
moving away with in some states more
than others
from on the day voting now analysis of
the early voting
suggests that it gives the democrats a
substantial advantage that they had
just remember the third with that baked
in
registered democrats have returned 1.4
million ballots
registered republicans only 653 000
remaining
are unaffiliated now donald trump and
mike pence are already calling foul play
repeatedly the democrats are cheating
mail and ballots are open to widespread
fraud rick let me come to you mark our
card on mail-in balances we would call
them
on this side of the atlantic postal
votes um
are they more subject to fraud are they
fraudulent
uh no statistically uh it's it's not the
case
but they are more subject to being
spoiled
to not being counted and that's the
irony of this is that trump is
absolutely right when he says that a
vote in person
is more of a sure thing than a that than
one mailed
uh through the post office lots of
uh envelopes will go undelivered partly
because
the postal service is being starved of
funds by the
trump administration but also because
a lot of people don't know how to fill
out a mail in an absentee ballot and
the example i use is in nevada which is
again a hotly
contested battleground state you have a
huge number of latino democrats
not all of whom are proficient in
english who have to remember
to sign their their the outer envelope
of their mail-in ballot when they send
it in now
inevitably thousands and thousands of
them are going to forget
to sign their names and those ballots
those
votes will be rejected automatically and
it's different in every state every
state has different rules
uh but i cannot for for for the life of
me understand
why the democratic party is not calling
for a
massive in-person turnout to block
what they imagine is going to be a trump
uh
riot uh a trump subversion
a trump overthrow of the constitution a
coup d'etat
you have to read the american press the
scare stories that are going around now
it started in early september it's been
going on for a long time
if you really want to block uh a coup
d'etat by trump
encourage your people to vote uh uh in
person
especially because of all the spoiled
ballots that are going to
are going to occur it could lose them uh
certain states now again
the democratic party is the is the party
of
uh caution and masks
uh the republican party and trump are
the party of
anti-mass and voting in person and less
caution
that's his only hope is that massive
numbers of
uh maskless uh republicans turn out
in person and vote and he's able to say
hey i'm ahead on election day
while they're counting the ballots in
this day or that day and it goes on for
weeks and weeks
and things are truly destabilized
democrats are not responding to that
possibility
mallory we're working on the assumption
that
uh a lot more of mr trump's
base will vote on the day than mr
biden's
base and there are a lot more of mr
biden's base will
use mail-in votes than mr trump's uh uh
um base is that uh there's pulling
evidence to suggest that is that right
there is polling evidence to suggest
that democrats are more comfortable with
voting
early by mail and republicans are more
in favor of voting
in person part of that as rick mentioned
is to do with the
huge disparities in beliefs around covid
and
risk factors and behaviors now what's
important to note is that
our polling is also showing that
americans are generally
concerned about the integrity of the
election
next month but the concerns vary based
on your partisanship
so as we've sort of alluded to uh
republicans are much more concerned
about mail-in voter fraud
and the integrity of the election if
people were to vote by mail
and democrats on the other hand are much
more concerned about things like voter
suppression
so i think that's why we're starting to
see not only a behavioral split
between the two parties but also a
difference in how
each party is messaging around voting to
their supporters
because what we can all agree on is that
we're concerned
about election integrity but where the
parties definitely differ
is what that means and what those
concerns are
i do think that uh democracy at a
distance
democracy at remove and remove is a bad
optic as they say i don't think it looks
good
you know and people turning out and
saying yes i'm going to vote in person
make sure my vote counts
i don't see again why don't the
democrats just promise to distribute
free masks and hand sanitizer in front
of every polling place in the country
and get their people to turn out on the
day because their votes are
the key to this rick i think i'm right
i'm saying is the key is that if you
turn out on the day because
uh you've got machine voting in the
united states your votes are counted on
the day and counted quickly
unlike mail votes correct
amber let me come to you uh now mr trump
in particular
has been saying you know that these
mailboxes they're open to fraud
they're fake votes they can't be trusted
i would suggest that
the evidence for that is quite slight
but what mail in voting
does do because you've got postmarks
you've got signatures
you've got envelopes within envelopes
and is that envelope inside open there
isn't it
that it's a dripping roast for lawyers
you have got
huge scope to challenge mail in voting
in a way that you don't
for voting on the day isn't isn't that
the case
that's exactly right because there are
so many things that can go wrong with a
mail-in ballot
you're already looking at a much longer
time frame
for when these votes get counted as well
as potential challenges
legally to the validity of those ballots
and i think what trump is doing here
by floating the idea of fraud is
multiple things
one he's opening up the idea that if he
does lose it could be because there was
cheating involved
and he said and he's prepared to
challenge that and then number two as
has been alluded to by rick he wants to
make sure that people in the republican
party who intend on voting for him
who might still be wary of the
coronavirus are more scared of the idea
of their vote not being counted then
they are by potentially getting the
virus that they are inclined to show up
on election day and vote in person
because of course that is obviously an
advantage that the president has
i understand that now i want to put to
you all
as representatives of the commentariat
that you're all obsessed by looking in
your
rear view mirror with 2016 and i don't
speak
about you personally in this but the
commentariat
got 2016 generally wrong uh they thought
hillary clinton was going to win
and she didn't and that has made them
much more wary
of saying what they really believe which
is they do think joe biden's going to
win
but they got it wrong and probably going
to win well but they got it so wrong in
2016 they're looking in the rear view
mirror
and they're just too nervous to see it
but that is what they think
isn't that true freddie i think almost
certainly
uh you would hear a lot more uh hubris
uh certainly among democratic-leaning
pollsters uh
this time but i'd also add i think in
sort of strange ways and i'm sure if so
this is not the case with ipsos
but i often think when pollsters tell
you they've got a more sophisticated
model
for uh making sure that they're counting
non-college-educated voters which will
help them
uh weight it more towards a fair
interpretation of trump i start thinking
oh dear you know when you're when you
think you're doing something to make it
more accurate and you're making the
process more complicated
inevitably that means the polling is
less accurate very often i think
so in many ways the ways in which
they've tried to change polling
to make it more reflective of the
american population might just warp it
even more
mother i better go straight to you for
that
certainly well one thing that i think is
different now
than in 2016 is that polls at the
national level have been remarkably
consistent
you know i've noted this a couple times
the president's approval rating
is flat it remains steady polling the
national horse race has remained steady
and yes we have to remember that i think
we have to be cautious about how we talk
about polling
both pollsters and others speaking about
polls publicly
right as i mentioned this is designed to
be a snapshot in time what the american
public thinks right now
polls are not intended to be forecasting
models
right that's not what we do and so i
think
we just have to do our best to ensure
that
our polling is reflective of who is
likely to vote in 2020
but it is worth noting that things have
been
a lot steadier this time around and
there's another differentiating factor
that i'd note which is that
joe biden is hovering right around or
now just above
that magic 50 threshold which
at this time in 2016 hillary clinton was
still underneath
interesting amber if it wasn't for 2016
we'd all be seeing it so it's over
father-shouting
i think that's exactly right every
pundit even ones
that are lean republican i think are
worried
about getting it wrong so badly like
they did in 2016
because of of course the embarrassment
that comes with that the i told you so's
and also the perception that americans
just don't listen to them anymore that's
a huge
uh that's obviously a huge worry among
the punditry class
because if americans
don't listen to them if what they have
to say doesn't matter
then they are at risk of losing their
power losing their jobs losing their
money
and that i think is the real fear that's
associated
with people being more cautious about
making bold predictions
and instead trying to toe the line and
really uh not make any predictions at
all
you see rick the reason i think i'm onto
something this is because i'm influenced
by what happened in
britain too when theresa may caught her
snap election in 2017 she didn't have to
do it
but she did the commentary on even
though they looked at her campaign and
wondered how could anybody run
a campaign as badly as this the
commentary
but on the left and the right by and
large thought she
was going to get in with a bigger
majority in fact she lost a majority
altogether
so when it came tonight 2019 even though
when you look back on
nearly all the objective measures it was
clear that boris johnson
was going to win and win quite
comfortably
the commentary act wouldn't say so
because they were looking
in their rear view where mirror and what
had happened in 2017 and i'm
drawing an analogy between the same in
america 2016
and now i'll give you the last word on
that
i i have a great dodge uh of your
question which is that i
i predicted hillary clinton would lose
way back in the fall of two wow
2015 but i thought she'd lose to jeb
bush
but i don't look back so much at 2016.
i'm looking at brexit and i very much
think of this
as a referendum on trump not a contest
between trump
and biden uh and if it's a referendum
then anything can happen if it's yes and
no and
the great failure of the pollsters in in
the uk was they didn't count
the non-voters right there were a lot of
people who came out and voted for the
first time for someone you've never
voted before absolutely right and the
polls didn't pick them up
but the difference between that and this
is that uh uh
trump is so weak as a candidate now and
is
is so self-destructive you don't have
much to vote for
you don't have dominic cummings advising
trump
so uh i'm not sure how he wins a
referendum
i think on on the referendum basis
he loses it's going to be a no vote
against trump
the only thing so not a vote for mr
biden
a vote against mr trump
so the way to look at this the
presidential election is not really as a
presidential election it's a is it yes
for trump or no for trump
exactly and the only way trump i guess
could
pull it out of the fire is if the left
which didn't like biden you know there's
a huge
uh reform left faction that supported
either uh bernie sanders or elizabeth
warren
if they don't come out they don't vote
or they forget to vote
i guess there's still a chance he could
win the referendum
by default but it doesn't seem likely at
this point
it's a really interesting way of looking
at i will now
steal that from eureka and recycle in
in a totally unprofessional way
without any attribution whatsoever at
least
i guess freddie gray mallory newell
amber
apha john rick mcarthur thank you so
much
for being with us on spectator tv we've
run out of time
just a reminder if you want to hear more
from the spectators journalists
that we've had on this program subscribe
to the spectators
wonderful monthly american edition and
spectator dot u s
forward slash subscribe you'll get a
discount if you enter the code tv
not too difficult to let us tv and of
course you get access to
all of our wonderful online and digital
products including our fantastic
newsletters
so do it now don't delay thanks to you
all
we'll see you again next week bye
you